the fastest way to learn a language the
fastest way to learn Japanese is not
from a textbook it's not from going to
classes it's to go to Japan you need to
immerse yourself in the environment
whatever the thing is that you want to
be great at the more you are around it
people who are doing it people who are
speaking it people who are living it the
more it will rub off onto you and the
faster it will rub off onto you now it
can be a physical environment or it
could also be from the content that
you're consuming I get it a lot from my
own YouTube videos because I feel like
I'm around Steve Jobs and Elon Musk and
Oprah Winfrey every single day and the
more you immerse yourself in that
environment the more their mindset the
more their motivation the more their
confidence is going to stick with you to
help you go be world class the thing
that you want to be great at